hey guys this miguel concepción a
tattered gamespot with jean-luc hello we
are here to talk about fallout for vr we
both had some hands-on time with it
jean-luc what were your general
impressions well this is 5 I've played
variety of ER games this year and this
is I've actually played all the pathetic
VR games and there were a lot of things
about this that I found appealing but
also pretty mixed and to negative it
seems to be a trend in a lot of these
ports of games that originated on
consoles and PC non VR I had a similar
experience too
it was no surprise you know
fiddling around in the house that you
started getting used to the direct
movement and trying out the
teleportation and even just getting to
the crib you know that was a challenge
in itself
but in classic Fallout style I started
with my head in in the mirror like in
the wall well like when you're supposed
to do the character creator like my head
was just stuck in there war never
changes you're gonna knock him dead at
the veterans hall tonight hon you think
sorry it's Bethesda games janky let's uh
yeah not not to give make excuses for
the chunkiness but yes we were earlier
we were talking about the UI and like
you know Fallout 4 was not didn't
getting much recognition or accolades
for his user interface so it was already
kind of at a disadvantage of going into
VR but I mean we tried to make the most
of it yeah it just it feels clumsy in VR
in a way that VR is like supposed to be
very intuitive and I think part of that
was the like they make some good efforts
so for example the Pip Boy is directly
on your arm and like in though kind of
the way you'd imagine it you actually
take your left arm and you pull it up to
your hand or your face and you can see
like the pip-boy it'll actually like
expand and like blows up and you can
like read the screen how about the
expanding thing was kind of weird like
that sort of took me out of it you can
adjust that which is cool but a problem
is that okay now I have it to my face
instinctively you'd be like oh I can
like mess with the dials like with your
other hand but
that's not a thing you can do it's you
have to use the scroll wheel on the five
controller and that just like I'm
sitting there holding it like this kind
of scrolling it she's feels really
awkward it seems to be a nice compromise
over actually expecting Bethesda from
creating a pip-boy device that's
integrated with it with the VR I mean
that's a pipe dream that's the dream
that's the dream it's like my
collector's edition suddenly like works
in the VR like fully right that would be
so cool I mean I'll be like thinking
about the first I mean the first moment
where the VR sort of like sold me a sort
of like a strength in in experiencing
Fallout 4 and for me it was actually
going down the elevator for the first
time in vault one-one-one actually going
down as the nuclear explosion happened
and the natural impulse to look up as
you're going down the elevator I'm like
this is cool obviously you can do that
in the traditional game but in the VR it
just takes it to another level for me
was when I was like walking around the
world just kind of like be able to
experience the world and like kind of
appreciate the the look and the scale of
everything he's like really cool there
are some weirdnesses I had so I played
Resident Evil 7 in VR and that game was
I don't know when they started building
it for VR but they I came came out with
VR so they obviously had put a lot of
thought into VR when they were designing
that game and the games like our
aesthetic feels like a real place and
everything proportionally feels correct
like you feel like I am in this house
and fallout everything feels slightly
off like characters feel slightly
smaller than they should like then in
real life door handles feel like
slightly lower like I at first I thought
actually I was like sinking into the
floor like the calibration wasn't
correct but it actually was right and my
character model is just like really tiny
so it's this weird thing where you don't
think about it when you're playing a
game normally on the TV and I imagine
the developers they built the game for
traditional like you know game playing
experiences so they can kind of make
them look a little more cartoonish in
proportions but when you translate that
into VR where it's supposed to be this
like seamless experience
suddenly it has like this weird uncanny
valley effect where you're like this
doesn't feel quite right right and it I
mean going off at that point it was sort
of comforting that when you fight your
first enemies which were the cockroaches
you didn't necessarily have to like bend
down despite the fact you were always
punching down yeah
and you also make an interesting point
of I mean comparing it to the Resident
Evil 7 I mean this is a game that was a
suit I mean presumably built without VR
and mind right and now we're thinking
now I'm like thinking about what games
are in development now that we know
about that we're probably gonna play in
our consoles and PCs but might have like
a VR team you know from the ground up
yeah like it wasn't even ten away that's
kind of what I feel like a lot of these
Bethesda games are right now is that
they are sort of implementing older
franchises with VR to test the waters of
building VR and I can see the end game
being well the next follow or the next
Elder Scrolls will have VR built in from
the ground up right as opposed to we're
just sort of tacking it on and then you
get all these problems like well the UI
doesn't really feels clumsy in VR and
the proportions kind of feel off and the
aiming feels weird like the shooting in
this game feels inaccurate and it's kind
of that way in Fallout by design but in
VR it feels especially infuriating like
trying to aim with a gun I had such a
hard time and they give you the VATS
system which kind of like slows
everything down and you can like kind of
see where like if you're aiming at a
guy's head so that helps but compared to
like other games that like more
naturally fit like shooting a gun in VR
like super hot like I just I felt like I
was aiming at a dude and then like I
just wasn't
but earlier we were talking you were
talking about Amy it speaks to maybe
like the Lord the the kind of immersion
that playing Fallout 4 in VR did for you
but you were talking about how you were
resting the rifle on your arm despite
the fact that you you really weren't
doing that in the game but yes
stabilizing it for your own immersion
totally yeah so like the you have the
pistol like pistols and and basic melee
weapons feel pretty good with the vibe
like controllers like it makes sense
that has like the same weight to it
the second you're holding like a rifle
it feels weird like you're like oh like
this shouldn't this should have more of
a weight to it in my hand that was
something I really liked about Doom VR
on the PlayStation is if you have that
via gleich two-handed aim controller it
actually feels really good holding guns
with that like it feels like correct
weight to it but it's kind of weird
because you'd think like okay I'm
holding this rifle one-handed I would
want to like shoot with the hip that
doesn't make sense I'm not gonna be able
to shoot anything with it so the other
thing is okay well if I like move it
really close so you're gonna like clip
into the model and then you can like see
the crosshair you're kind of making your
own version of like a aim-down-sights
but then that hayden still feels weird
so kind of the weird compromise I made
was like well in fiction if I was
holding a rifle one-handed you rest it
on your arm and kind of shoot like that
so I was trying to like come up with my
own like in fiction reason for why my
character would be holding a rifle
one-handed which was probably not their
intent but it kind of I think that just
speaks to the overall feelings of VR is
that as a player you want to be immersed
and you want to like come up with like
logical reasons for why this would
behave that way and like why I would be
doing it and trying the best to make it
as immersive as possible I feel like the
game just by virtue of being a part of a
game that wasn't meant for VR keeps kind
of pulling you out right which is a nice
segue into the movement of the game
like many first-person games in VR it
has direct movement or you have the
choice of teleporting when you play
Resident Evil or you play doom you can
use the stick to move with the directly
and that feels fine because it's a stick
right it's a traditional like joystick
with the five you're using that slide
pad and that's just it feels clumsy it
feels company to try and move with the
direct movement so I ended up actually
using the teleport and I in those other
games actually prefer the direct
movement I have like an iron stomach
when it comes to VR so I can handle that
and I don't so yeah for people like you
your only option is to use the teleport
but and this one I ended up preferring
to teleport and it actually did work
better in this game than Skyrim where in
Skyrim any time you're in a small
environment and you're trying to very
precisely be like I want to get to that
table and pick up an apple both with the
direct movement and the teleport it felt
kind of clumsy your light kind of like
forcing your way to this spot with the
vive the advantage is that you can kind
of teleport close and then you can
actually just like physically walk over
in that space and pick something up so
fallout definitely has the advantage on
that front which is nice and I think if
he did spend a lot of time on it you
will be able to like find this sort of
these control nuances and it will offer
viously like demand a lot of stamina for
a game that is gonna take you at least
like 50 70 hours to beat thinking about
like my final thoughts another thing
that really sold me on it when we're
talking about exploration at is taking
in the environment was when I actually
got out of the vault just be like take
in the blue sky and like looking around
was was a really great feeling and
reuniting with our robot Butler
Cogsworth was his name yeah talking to
him and actually while I'm listening to
him I'm actually like bending down I'm
actually somewhat appreciating all his
little details things that obviously you
can do again with traditional controller
and a console but it was it was just
fascinating just to just like been down
and to sort of appreciate his details
and it made me think about like the best
context in which to play fallout born
for VR and that is I think I would best
enjoy this after
finishing all the story content and it
and that makes it disappointing that you
can't use your fallout your old fallout
4 PC saves to just jump straight into a
world that you've already like mostly
unlocked and just explore that way you
actually have to start from the
beginning of the game yeah I think your
best bet is to find someone who's done
all that work for you on the PC and
there's like uploaded that file to like
a mega upload and you just like download
that for you and then you just put it in
the game and play that is that possible
probably don't come any closer friend
this doesn't concern you
please help they're going to kill me
shut up
you're not killing anyone says you so
now you played all three Bethesda VR
games that came out what's your informal
ranking normal ranking so they all have
I'd say their benefits and their
problems I think the advantage of all
Skyrim and fallout is that there is
nothing else like them in VR in terms of
is like a scope of a world like there is
no other VR game where you can wander
around this massive environment and play
you know hundreds of hours of content so
there is something to be said about
those as opposed to doom which is a much
more like tighter you know like three
four hour experience but I would say
that doom is probably like the better
playing game like mechanically like I
had more fun playing it in VR although
even in that case there were times where
I felt like the VR kind of got in the
way and then I was like man this would
probably be better with the controller
so it's it's hard for me to recommend
any of them
outright I feel like if you are someone
who's like a VR aficionado in the sense
that you want like a truly immersive
experience I don't think any of these
are really like providing that fully but
if you're somebody who like really likes
fallout and happens to have like a VR
headset like you said it's really cool
like you get to experience this world in
like a new way and you get to like
appreciate
like these intricate details about it
you wouldn't get to normally well there
you have it if you'd like to learn more
about these Bethesda VR games we have a
whole bunch of videos and write-ups
thanks for watching
you
[Music]